good morning John time for a truth bomb
you and I have had a good month but you
gotta admit that there's no way we could
do any of the things that we do without
this community frankly nerdfighteria is
my biggest inspiration that means that
when i don't have an idea for a video i
can just ask on twitter and tumblr and
also instagram though instagram on the
internet doesn't show me all the
comments why why it's not a complicated
feature show more give me a link that's
right I'm already doing it I'm taking
your suggestions on what I should do
with my video today that was a good idea
I'm here today with a sidewalk to talk
about what it's like to be a sidewalk so
sidewalk what do you think well I got no
complaints they accept tree roots don't
get me started on tree roots fascinating
one day I had an idea when I was bored I
was like Bernie what do you think of the
people from prank critics we're vloggers
but that idea would win an Annie Award
the technically people like it is
totally bonkers this is a book you may
have heard of
it's called Emma it's by Jane Austen and
some friends of mine are about to adapt
it into a video blog series so maybe you
want to read up
I want a Wonder Woman movie right like
that needs to exist didn't you know that
Joss Whedon wanted to do one and Warner
Brothers turned him down
the person who made that decision needs
to eat a can of poop lever poop
pretty good actually I was all ready to
talk about how terrible this was ah
Hey
I deal with stress in two ways so there
are two kinds of stress there's stress
that you can take care of and there's
stress
did you can't the first one I take care
of it as fast as possible because
putting it off always makes it worse
things that I can't fix
I think about the fact that I can't fix
them I think about why I can't fix them
and I come to terms with the fact that
this is a problem that I'm not going to
overcome and that the world is not a
wish-granting Factory all right speech
jammer I already downloaded it putting
my headphones on this is a very long
cord this is the free one we're going to
stop speech jammers work by playing your
voice back into your ears right after
you use speed it interferes with the
kind of cognitive cognitive skog Natisha
cuts it becomes at the epoch of this
difficult couple and dip to make sure
it's very difficult to speak
minute things are going good scishow and
crash course is going well sighs you
just hit a million subscribers
subbable I should talk about this is a
difficult thing launching a product and
we had a snafu with Amazon and the
ability to take recurring payments so if
you set up a monthly subscribership it
got canceled out so you need to go back
to subbable sign in and we up your
subscription because amazon freaked out
on us because we weren't following all
their rules correctly now we are a
bobble has been extremely successful and
if everybody goes back in and actually
redoes their subscription then crash
course is going to be safe but right now
only 50% of people have done that so if
you haven't please do thanks for all the
fantastic ideas this was a really weird
video John I'll see you on Tuesday
you